Hello, class.
This lecture
will focus on
antipsychotics.
And in the lecture,
I will distinguish
between the positive and
negative symptoms
of schizophrenia.
I will describe
typical antipsychotics.
And with this
mechanism, it's going
to be about blocking
the two receptors.
And with that,
there's going to be
adverse effects
that will come up.
Among them will be
the Parkinsonism.
So I will discuss ways we
manage these
adverse effects.
Next is going to be
the second generation,
and these are atypical
antipsychotics.
With these drugs,
the blockade is
going to be at the
serotonin 2A receptors,
but I will say there's
going to be some
modest blockade of the
dopamine receptors,
And there'll be
some drugs, mainly
aripiprazole, that
can actually be a
partial agonist of
the dopamine receptor.
And understand that
with the atypicals,
you can treat
other conditions.
Bipolar depression
will be some
of the things that
can be managed
with the typical
antipsychotics.
so schizophrenia
and psychosis are
categorized as positive
symptoms and this is
where you see the
patient being delusional
they'll be agitated
they'll be hallucinating
they'll have
some degree of
disorganized thinking
it's almost like an acting
out if you want to
think of it in this
way and that is
where typicals have
their main effect and
these positive symptoms
are coming from the
mesolimbic area.
Negative symptoms are
kind of like where
I would say the
patient is more like
flat. They're apathetic.
They're isolating.
They have poor
speech. And this is
where the atypicals
have a really good
profile at managing. And
the negative symptoms
will come for the
mesocortical area.
So before we had
all these new drugs
that are used to
treat psychosis and
bipolar depression,
we only had the
drugs that block
dopamine. And this
was due to the
dopamine hypothesis.
And it has been
shown over and over
again that a person
who's schizophrenic
will have an excess
of dopamine in
the mesolimbic
system. And that makes
sense because that
is why they present
with the agitation
and the delusions.
Other things that
they noted is that in
untreated schizophrenics
at post-mortem
study, they had an
increase in D2 receptors.
In addition, there seems
to be higher levels
of urinary
homovanillic acid in
schizophrenics. And we
also know that drugs that
increase dopamine or
inhibit the reuptake
induce psychotic
behavior. And that's true.
When we talked about
amantidine in the PD
lecture, we said one
of the things that
you would expect
with higher levels of
dopamine, whether it
be with the mantidine
or even the dopamine
agonist, is that some
patients can have
different behaviors,
whether it be delusions,
hallucinations.
And the same thing
with *******.
Even though with
******* we think about
the heart and the whole
idea of the vitals
being off, the patient
does present with
very disorganized
thinking. they'll be
hallucinating, and as
we saw in a previous
lecture, one of the ways
we manage that is by
giving a typical
antipsychotic like
chaloperidol, and that
makes sense due to the
reuptake inhibition
that ******* affords.
So the dopamine 2
receptor is going
to be mainly with
mechanism and the
physiology is going
to be G-inhibitory.
So dopamine will,
in fact, bind to
the receptor.
You're going to get
dissociation of
the alpha and beta
from the beta
and gaba subunit.
And then you're going
to see a decrease in
adenyl cyclase, a
decrease of cyclic AMP,
a decrease ultimately
in protein kinase A,
and all of the
transcription factors will
be affected, and that
is in the nucleus.
So G-inhibitory
for D2 receptors.
And this is an important
slide because it
kind of shows you
where everything goes.
So in the mesolimbic
area, that is where
the positive symptoms
of schizophrenia are
happening. Okay, so
for example, if I am
giving something like
haloperidol to my
patient who is having
a psychotic episode,
what's going to
happen is D2 is going
to block here.
And that is what
we would want. We
want that patient
to be soothed as
soon as possible.
But the issue is
that, and this
is one of now where we're
talking about the
adverse effects.
If you're blocking
in the mesocortical
area, that patient
is going to be very
flat after getting
this medication. And
many times, if
anyone has worked in
psychiatry, they say
after giving haloperidol,
the patient is
pretty much flat,
apathetic.
And then the other
things that start to
happen is that if
you're blocking D2
receptors in the tubular
infundibular area,
now you're going to
get an increase in
prolactin. and that
becomes a problem
when we're talking
about menstruation
and fertility and
things of that nature.
And possibly the
most important one,
and that we've
covered before, when
you're blocking D2 in
the nigrostriadium,
you're going to get the
presentation of
Parkinsonism. And this,
hopefully now that
you've had the PD
lecture, and now we're
doing this, you start
to tie in the concepts.
And this is really
where the problem
was when patients,
before we had the
atypicals, many patients
ended up having these
issues. And I'll
talk about how we
manage them coming up.
So the typical
antipsychotics are
sometimes known as
the first generation.
They're going to block
D2 in the mesolimbic
area, and they're
going to block
both pre- and
postsynaptic D2 receptors.
But as I mentioned,
if you're blocking in
the mesocortical area,
those D2 receptors,
you're going to worsen
the negative symptoms.
If you're blocking D2
in the nigrostriadium,
you're going to get
rigidity, tremors,
or the classic
presentation
of Parkinson's disease.
And then if you're
blocking D2 in the
tubal and fundibular
pathway, you're
going to get an
increase in prolactin.
So typical antipsychotics
do have several uses.
Schizophrenia, drug
-induced psychosis. So
as I mentioned, that
patient that comes into
the ED with a *******
overdose, yes, we're
going to be worried
about the blood pressure
and heart rate, but
they're going to be
hallucinating and being
somewhat combative.
you would give something
like haloperidol.
The next two have
been largely replaced
with the atypicals.
And that can be, again,
the idea of using them
for bipolar disorder
and also for patients
that have dementia.
Okay, so we talked
a little bit about
Alzheimer's in the
previous lecture. We talked
about the cholinesterase
inhibitors and the
NMDA receptor antagonists.
but these patients
will also have symptoms
of, say, agitation.
They can be
delusional. They can be
hallucinating. And using
an atypical at a small
dose may sometimes be
effective to manage
some of those behavioral
attributes that
happened with dementia.
And then we do have,
and I did mention again,
when we were talking
about Parkinson's
disease, when you give
patients something
that affords dopamine,
you're going to get
a degree of nausea
and vomiting. And I
did mention that there
are dopamine receptors
in the chemo trigger
zone. So if you
agonize, you're going
to get more of the
feeling of nausea and
vomiting. So it makes
sense when we block
those D2 receptors
in the chemo trigger
zone with something
like metaclopamide,
it makes sense
that that would
make that
feeling go away.
And then lastly,
with Tourette's,
which tends to
happen in the
pediatric population,
it has to do with an
imbalance of dopamine.
And in the past, they
used mainly Pimazide,
and that's sometimes
still used. They're
using Aripiprazole a
little bit more lately
because, again, of the
adverse effects. And
remember, with Tourette's,
this imbalance of
dopamine can manifest
into motor tics or
even voice tics. and
these are things that
happen that that patient
has no control over.
So that's just a little
bit about the
indications.
And these are the drugs
and I will say probably
the one that you
should definitely most
identify with is going
to be probably these
four and of course
Pimazide because of their
effects on managing
Tourette's syndrome.
So, here is
now the adverse
effects. Number one,
these drugs, especially
when I talk about
low potency, they're
going to have a
degree of muscarinic,
histaminic, and
alpha-1 blockade. And
that would mean that
the patient can
have, with muscarinic
blockade, perhaps
difficulty urinating.
With H1 block, they
can be sedated.
There can be a degree
of weight gain.
And then, of
course, with alpha-1
blockade and how those
are present on the
arterioles, if you're
blocking, you're
going to bring down
the blood pressure,
and that's going
to be orthostatic.
Of course, EPS,
the dystonia and the
pseudoparkinsonism,
that's coming from
blocking D2 in the
nigrostriadium.
We also have a condition
known as akathisia.
and akathisia is basically
where the patient
has a degree of
restlessness they can
experience say anxiety
fidgeting and probably
the biggest one is the
restless legs and then
we have menstrual
irregularities that comes
from blocking d2 in
the tubal infundibular
area and then we have
tardive dyskinesia and
NMS, which I will talk
about in a moment,
with NMS being rare,
but it could be fatal.
So talking about the
serotonin receptors,
the alpha, which
makes sense for this
lecture, the muscarinic,
the histamine, and
then the vasopressin,
which that will be
next year, understand
that they are going
to be GQ okay so with
GQ the agonist will
bind as you can see
alpha is dissociating
from the beta and gamma
and now you're going
to get an enhancement
with GQ of
phospholipase C and that's
going to now have an
effect on increasing
IP3 and DAG and that
also will activate
protein kinase C and
now you're going to
go from the calcium
being stored into the
cell as free calcium.
So with Tardive
dyskinesia, this
is like the name
says, Tardive.
It doesn't happen
in a month.
It happens over the
course of months
to maybe even years
after starting
these medications.
And this has
to do when you
block D2 receptors,
eventually you're going
to start upregulating.
And what tardive
dyskinesia ended up
happening with the
patient, they would have
these episodes where
things that they couldn't
control were happening.
Out of nowhere,
their tongue would
protrude. they would
have lip smacking they
would have something
called perioral
syndrome which is
almost like we call it
rabbit syndrome if you
ever seen a rabbit
move its nose and mouth
up and down this is
how tar dive would
present and you know
here is the thing
with something like
tar dive You know,
schizophrenia is usually
diagnosed in a patient's
teens or maybe, you
know, early 20s.
And, you know, back
in the day, there
was a degree of
stigma with this.
And, you know, just
to know that you
have this disorder
was bad enough for
those patients.
But the fact that
some of these
medications that we still
have that were
used to treat
schizophrenia were
causing these symptoms,
this oftentimes led
to the patient not
being compliant with
their medication.
And that is definitely
a big problem,
not just for the
patient, but if you're
talking about public
health in general.
So again, these are
still used in certain
cases. but the newer
generation, you're
going to see as you
go into your rotations
with psychiatry, you're
going to see that
we'll use these when
we have to, and then we
will take over with
the atypicals. And
that's exactly how we
would manage TAR Dive.
You start with the
lowest dose, assess
the patient, and
once that patient is
controlled well, you
will use an atypical.
the other thing about
tar dive is that
there was no going
back from it and that
was another deep
concern because once you
started having these
symptoms of your tongue
just coming out of
your mouth out of
nowhere that was
usually lifelong and one
thing that has come
to to market it is
something called a VMAT
inhibitor. And these
are two drugs. There's
valbenazine and
dutrabenazine. And
I will say that
they are also used
for Huntington's
disease because with
Huntington's disease,
even though it's
genetic, there's
an imbalance of dopamine
in the striadium.
so there's high
dopamine levels.
What VMAT inhibitors
do is they're
going to, as you
can see here,
they really are going
to stop the transport
of dopamine to the
synaptic vessel.
So if you're not
getting dopamine here,
obviously you're not
going to get dopamine here
in the synapse to bind
to the postsynaptic
receptors. And by doing
that, you stop the
whole idea of Tardive.
So these medications
are relatively new.
They're pretty costly,
but they do help with
Tardive dyskinesia.
Okay. And that's
basically the idea is to
just cut off dopamine
going into the synapse
and binding to the
postsynaptic receptors.
The drug is related
to reserpine.
So reserpine, you
might have already
discussed it. You may
talk about it when
you do antihypertensives.
This is not a
medication that we
use for high blood
pressure anymore
because it cuts down all
of these transmitters,
dopamine,
norepinephrine, and to
an extent, serotonin.
And it's good to know
through its mechanism,
but we wouldn't use
reserpine because
one of the problems
that we saw with
reserpine when
patients had nothing
available and they used
it for hypertension
is that they did
become depressed.
Okay, so I just wanted
to connect reserpine
in case you read it
in your readings.
Some of the adverse
effects is that it
can increase QT
intervals. So it will
be important that
you do a baseline
EKG before starting
a VMAT inhibitor.
Sedation, as I
mentioned, because you
are cutting off
neurotransmitters. And
there are also
substrates for SIP. So if
you gave an inhibitor
of SIP, say like
grapefruit juice, you
may raise the level
of the VMAT inhibitor
and that can cause
more sedation or
problems with the QT.
And remember, the
increase in QT has to do
with the fact that
you're prolonging
repolarization and that
has to do with closure
of the potassium
channels of the heart.
As mentioned, NMS
is considered to
be a very rare
adverse effect, but
it's important
you understand the
malignant hypothermia
involved with
this syndrome?
Because it does happen
sometimes in
those patients who
have had surgery
and they were
given a halogenated
anesthetic.
With NMS, the
patient is going to
present with severe
muscle rigidity.
That means if you
touch them, it's
almost going to be
like a lead pipe.
They're going to be
unconscious. They're
going a degree of
tachycardia their temperature
will be high they'll
be sweating and
the other thing that's
related to the muscle
rigidity is the
elevated in creatine
kinase and this happens
when you are having
sustained muscle
contraction which is caused
by the muscle rigidity
which is causing
muscle rigidity and
in essence the fever.
NMS does not happen
rather quickly.
It happens weeks
to months later.
There's no GI effects
because if you remember
from the previous lecture
with the serotonin
syndrome, serotonin
syndrome also had
a degree of tachycardia,
high fever, but it
also had GI effects
also serotonin syndrome
it was not rigidity
there was episodes of
myoclonic presentation
what do you do when
somebody has NMS where
you discontinue the
drug you provide
supportive care so that can
be something like cooling
blankets you would
have to manage the
vital signs and you
provide dantrolene
and I'll speak about
dantrolene in a moment
and bromocriptine and
remember bromocriptine
is a dopamine agonist
and that makes sense
because the nms is due
to the fact that you
are blocking the d2
receptors and once somebody
has nms they should
not be given a drug
like this in the future
if they have some
type of schizophrenia
psychosis they should
get the atypical so
again this chart you've
seen before and as you
can see the timing
for nms is going to be
gradual white serotonin
syndrome is abrupt
you're going to be
rigid with nms serotonin
syndrome you're going
to have some tremors
the reflexes are going
to be decreased with
nms maybe due to the
lead pipe rigidity
with serotonin syndrome
it's increased the
pupils will be normal
in nms with serotonin
syndrome they'll be
dilated and of course
what's going to make
the difference in
presentation and this
is what you have to
look for in a board's
question is the drugs
so anything that
doubles up on serotonin
is going to be
serotonin syndrome. So
that will be something
like taking maybe a
tryptan with fluoxetine,
which is an SSRI.
With NMS, it's
going to be mainly
the typical
antipsychotics. And the
other thing is the
halogenated drugs.
With the halogenated
drugs, there's going
to be something
called a mutation in
the ryanidine receptor.
And that's going
to make sense with
what I'm about to say.
The way we manage NMS
is with dantrolene.
This seeks to be
a muscle relaxant.
One thing to note,
and this is, you know,
people say with a
high fever, can you
give acetaminophen or
can we give an NSAID?
And the answer is
no, because the fever
is not coming from
a prostaglandin source.
The fever is coming
from the sustained
muscle contraction.
If your muscles
were contracting
consistently, that's
going to increase the
temperature. So what
you need to do is
to give something
that is going to bind
the ryanidine
receptor and prevent
calcium coming in
from the sarcolemma.
Once you have that,
then the calcium now
does not shuttle in
anymore and now the muscle
relaxes and that's
going to bring the
temperature down okay
so you'll also see
dantrolene not only given
for nms but also for
malignant hypothermia
and as i mentioned
with the halogenated
it has to do with the
fact that there's
some patients that may
have a genetic
predisposition that they have
a mutation in those
ryanidine receptors.
So now I'm going to
do specific adverse
effects. So as
a group, the D2
blockers will cause
the akathisia, the
NMS possibly, the
tardive, the EPS,
the Parkinsonism,
the high levels of
prolactin. But we have
chlorpromazine and
thiuridazine. And these
are sometimes called
low potency. Low
potency antipsychotics
means that they do
block the D2 receptors,
but what they block
more is going to be
the muscarinic histamine
and alpha block.
Okay. So something
like chlorpromazine is
going to have more
alpha one block than
say haloperidol. Okay.
The other thing is
thiuridazine has the
highest risk of causing
an increase in QT
interval. So again,
they're going to
prolong repolarization.
I'm going to say with,
I'm going to make
this a blanket
statement, with these
antipsychotics, and
you're going to see it now
with the newer drugs,
the atypicals, it's
a good idea to make
sure you get a baseline
EKG, okay, because
all of them have
some degree of increasing
the QT interval,
okay, diaritazine,
one of the most.
Flufenazine and
haloperidol are considered
high potency versus
chlorpromazine
and thiuridazine.
And the reason why is
they do block the
muscarinic histamine and
alpha receptors, but
their blockade is
going to be more on
D2 than the others.
Okay.
Thiuridazine is going
to cause something
called pigment retinopathy
where the patient
is going to see um
it's going to have
blurred vision they
may see almost um i
want to say almost like
a brown in in their
visual field okay
pigment and that has
to do with the fact
that the drug will um
deposit in the in the
melanin of eyes and
that can cause damage
to photoreceptors.
Chloropromazine,
and I have
it highlighted here, CNC,
they cause corneal
deposits. And
that's due to the
fact that there can be
some denaturing
of proteins in the
eye which can deposit
in the cornea.
And what that will
come as is that
the patient,
again, will have
blurred vision.
And they also will
have a degree of
light sensitivity.
So in the past, if
patients were on these
medications, which again,
not as much because
we have the newer
drugs, it would be very
important that they
got regular eye exams.
So the management of
adverse effects. number
one dystonia dystonia
is is very important
um what i want to
say about dystonia is
that this is a situation
where the patient
has involuntary muscle
contractions okay
and that can be in the
neck area it can be um
you know even in the
in the shoulders and
what happens with those
involuntary movements
they can get pain
so the the mechanism
is you know why is
this happening well it
seems to be that in
the basal ganglia okay
if you're blocking d2
receptors there's going
to be an increase
in acetylcholine so
there may be some
protocols and i know that
i I've spoken to some
physicians who either
worked in the ED or in
the psychiatric area
that when they gave
haloperidol, they would
follow up with some
muscarinic blocker.
Benadryl works fine, and
that's diphenhydramine,
or you could do
benstrapine. okay
and then for the the
symptoms of the eps it
wouldn't be incorrect
to give some amantadine
okay because remember
amantadine does
raise dopamine levels
and that could be
appropriate in a situation
like that and remember
even amantadine did
have some degree of
muscarinic block okay
so remember we talked
about amantadine when
we did parkinson's
disease this is the
one that cause the
levitoveticularis, that
molting of the skin.
Akathisia, and
I mentioned this
is when you're
getting almost
like a restlessness
of your legs.
The patient can present
as being very fidgety.
Usually what
they do for that
is that they
give propanolol.
And propanolol
is going to
modulate due to
its receptor block,
norepinephrine in the
CNS. But remember,
with propanolol, we
are going to deal
with not just beta
-1 block, but beta-2.
So if you're blocking
beta-2, you're
blocking the beta-2
receptors in the lungs,
and that can cause
more increase in, say,
asthma and COPD.
And then B2
receptor block, if
we're talking
about metabolics,
it will prevent the
conversion of glycogen
to glucose, and that can
lead to hypoglycemia.
So be mindful of
those adverse effects.
And then I said for
the NMS, with the lead
pipe rigidity, you
would give something
like dantrolene. And
remember, dantrolene
would block the
ryanidine or bind the
ryanidine receptor.
And that is going to
stop the calcium release
from the sarcolemma.
and that's going
to stop the severe
degree of muscle
contraction and rigidity.
So again, with
muscarinic antagonist,
they're going to help
with the dystonia.
They also help
with the tremor.
And remember, the
adverse effects, we
should probably know
by now. dry as a bone,
hot as a hair, the
heart runs alone,
mad as a hatter.
Again, going back to
the whole idea
that they can cause
tachycardia, they can
cause cognition issues,
they can cause
medriasis, they can
cause urinary
retention, constipation.
Make sure you're very
familiar with these
drugs because they're
going to be everywhere,
whether it be on
exams, boards, and
clinical practice so now
we shift to the serotonin
hypothesis and this
all came from ***
*** when patients take
it they do describe
a feeling of being
of hallucinating and
that's because ***
stimulates the serotonin to
a receptor so it makes
sense now that the
thought process was
if we can block those
receptors then those
effects can can go away
so a couple of things
that we need to um
to understand here
is that if you block
serotonin 2a receptors in
the tubal and fundibular
area there's not
going to be a release
of prolactin which is
going to be opposite
to what happens when
you block the d2
receptors in the
mesocortical area if you're
blocking the serotonin
2a receptors that in in
fact increases dopamine
and that is something
that we want in that
area because remember
when you blocked
dopamine with a d2
receptor like say
haloperidol the patient would
stop you know
hallucinating and having
agitation but they
would be prone to the
negative symptoms so if
you are blocking serotonin
2a receptors and
you're increasing
dopamine there the patient
is not going to have
those symptoms of
apathy and and social
isolation okay and in
the mesolimbic pathway
which is important if
you block 2a you don't
increase dopamine
levels so the patient
is not becoming more
psychotic in essence
okay so that is how
this hypothesis came out
so again not much
happening here with the
nigrostriadium not
much happening in the
infundibular area. As
a matter of fact, it
would shut down
prolactin release. In the
mesocortical area, you
would actually have
improvement. And here
in the mesolimbic
area, it's not doing
anything to, in fact,
increase dopamine levels.
Okay?
So, a couple of
things now that we
have to understand
because the atypicals
don't come without
adverse effects.
Number one, there may be
some degree of D2 block.
Obviously not as much
as a typical drug,
but you'll see that
there's a few drugs here
that can actually
have an effect on
prolactin, and that can
be due to the fact that
there may be some
d2 block coming from
those medications
okay ultimately you're
increasing dopamine
release in the mesocortical
area and that's
going to relieve the
negative symptoms and
that is now why we can
understand their use
in bipolar depression
And then the fact
that you're not having
much going on in the
nigrostriadium and the
tuba infundibular area,
you're not going to
worry about the
movement and the tremors
and the rigidity as you
would with haloperidol.
And neither would
you worry about the
increase in milk let
down by a D2 blocker.
all will prolong
the qt interval and
that makes sense
okay they can prolong
repolarization and
that can lead to an
increase in qt the
other thing that we
are dealing with with
these medications
that now is becoming
more long term
is that it can in
fact change appetite
There's effects on
several serotonin
receptors, and we did
hit upon it in the
antidepressant lecture.
There's going to be
some blockade of
histamine receptors with
some of them, and
we're starting to see
that patients are
complaining of weight
gain and hyperlipidemia
and maybe some
changes in A1C. So
this is going to be
very important that you
encourage the patient
to watch their diet
and to exercise.
And the possibility
is that some patients
may need to be put
on a statin or some
type of drug to manage
their blood glucose.
And then as you
see here, there's
going to be a bunch
of them that are
approved for manic
depression. The
first atypical was
clozapine, and I
will say that as of
today, it's still
available, but it's
going to be used
for treatment-resistant
schizophrenia,
okay?
The blockade is going
to be, as you can
see, there's going
to be some alpha-1,
which is going to
be greater than
serotonin-2a, and
serotonin-2a is going to
be greater than
D2. So that already
makes it that it's
not going to cause
the movement and
the prolactin story.
But it also has
an effect on H1.
One of the things
that some patients
experience with
clozapine is
something called a
nighttime drooling,
where they will wake
up in the morning
and they'll see that
their pillow is wet.
Why is this happening?
It hasn't really
been, you know, really
clarified, but they say
that there can be
some agonist activity
at the muscarinic 1 and
muscarinic 4 receptors.
And if that's the
case, then you can
understand the whole
idea of the salivation.
Weight gain has
to do with the
fact that there
is some blockade
at the serotonin
2C receptors.
And formerly,
we did have a
medication that was
an agonist of 2C,
locasorin.
It was taken off the
market because they
reported higher risk of
cancer with locasorin.
But that agonist was
used for weight loss.
So the block
here may be the
reason why that
this medication
and why some of
the others might
be causing the
weight gain.
Also H1 block.
H1 block in the
hypothalamus can
cause an increase
in fat accumulation.
And it also
increases a signaling
pathway that involves
AMP kinase. And if
that should be
enhanced, then you're
going to get an
increase in appetite.
The hypotension, if
you just see it here,
it has to do with
the alpha 1 block.
And then the
issue with this
medication is
that it causes
something called
agranulocytosis.
So if this medication
is to be started,
you have to do weekly
blood counts every
week for the first six
months of treatment.
If everything works
well, you do it every
two weeks from six to
12 months. And then
after that period,
after a year, you
could do this monthly.
But you have to do
regular CBCs. And
that was oftentimes a
problem for patients,
especially initially
when they had to go
every week to the lab.
So, if the patient
presents with a
sore throat, flu
-like symptoms,
good idea to do
the CBC as soon as
possible and remove
the medication.
This is the reason
why it's still
available, but this is
more for somebody who
has treatment-resistant
schizophrenia.
Aripiprazole
is one of the
medications we
need to consider.
Again, in this group and
in the next few slides,
understands that
all of these
drugs are going
to have a degree
of serotonin
to antagonism.
That's going to
be standard of the
atypicals. But aripiprazole
also has a partial
D2 and a partial
serotonin 1A agonism.
And what does
that mean to
you? Is that
if you recall,
buspirone was a partial
serotonin 1A agonist.
So it would make sense
that aripiprazole
can help, not just
with the bipolar the
schizophrenic and
the Tourette's it can
help with anxiety
irritability especially
in those that you
know have autism okay
the fact that it does
have some agonism now
not antagonism agonism
at the serotonin
2c receptors is the
reason why it may not
cause as much weight
gain than the other
drugs. And I'll talk
about those next.
And the other thing
that is important, it's
a substrate for 3A4
and 2D6. So again,
if you're taking the
grapefruit juice,
you're taking a
itraconazole, erythromycin,
you can raise the
levels of arypiprazole,
and that can lead to
more adverse effects.
So, arypiprazole,
going back
to the mesolimbic
pathway,
you're going to
have a decrease
in the positive symptoms.
And in addition, if
you're talking about
the mesocortical
area, you're not going
to have as much of
the negative symptoms.
So again, it's a nice
balance. You're not
inducing positive
symptoms, and you're
not inducing any of
the negative symptoms.
Brexiprepozole is
considered to have less
D2-intrinsic agonist
activity than
arepiprepozole, And it's
also more potent at the
serotonin-1A and the
serotonin-2A, okay?
And this one was
recently, I would say
in the last, I don't
know, three to five
years approved for
those patients that
have cognitive impairments
with agitation.
But the warning on
any of these, even
though they're widely
used, you have to
be very mindful
because they do have
an increase in reported
deaths, they say,
from these medications.
Again, is it
the medication or
is it other things?
We don't know for
now, but if you are
putting somebody who
has something like
AD on any of these,
it's a good idea to
make sure that they
are being closely
monitored and you're
also doing the
necessary lab work and,
of course, the EKG.
So olanzapine, I
would say of all the
atypicals, this is the
one that has the most
weight gain. And
that would make sense
because, again, it's
going to block the
serotonin 2A, but it
also has blockade of the
H1 and probably blockade
of the serotonin
2C. So that's what
makes it the most,
it has the highest
degree of weight gain.
But it does have
fewer EPS, it has less
autonomic nervous system
effects, and it is
approved in combination
with an SSRI for mania.
Quetiapine is a D2
blocker, but it doesn't
bind for a long
period of time. So if
that's the case, it's
not going to cause
the EPS and the
prolactin increase, as
we would say with a
strong D2 blocker.
It has minimal
muscarinic block,
but it has a
significant amount of
H1 and alpha-1
block. So because
of that, it's the
most sedative.
It has a risk
of orthostasis
because of the alpha-1.
this is the one that they
may give to the elderly
who become
agitated due to
cognition
issues but again
it's good that it
helps with that it
doesn't have muscarinic
blocks so it's
not adding to the
cognition liability
but I would also be
mindful that an alpha 1
blocker in that
population can lead to
orthostasis, and they can
run the risk of falls.
So again, this is
where the dosing
of your patient is
going to be very
important, depending
on the population,
especially
their age, their
kidney function,
liver function, etc.
Risperdone, I start
to hear that it's
widely used in certain
psychiatric wards.
But it does have
an increase in
prolactin, an increase in
hyperlipidemia,
and hyperglycemia.
So this one, again,
widely used, but I
would be concerned
with the metabolics.
And the H1 blockade
causing sedation
and weight gain,
and of course,
alpha-1 causing
hypotension.
Paliperidone is an
active metabolite of
risperidone. and
this one is is pretty
interesting is that it
can be given ****** every
day but it also can be
given intramuscularly
every month there's
a formulation at
a higher dose that's
every three months
and even every six
months so this is really
good if you're concerned
with compliance
because again
haloperidol flufenazine
used to be given
intramuscularly and the
good thing about those
is that you would
be the one giving it
to the to the patient
and you don't have
to worry about are
they being compliant
and this is the same
for pellet peridone
um zipricidone is a
a serotonin 2a blocker
but this one also
blocks the reuptake
of serotonin and
norepinephrine So it
almost acts like a
tricyclic or an SNRI.
So this would be very
nice for somebody with
bipolar depression.
Aside from the fact
that, again, H1 and
alpha block is going
to be part of this,
there can be a
rash that occurs.
And that rash could
lead to something
called Stephen
Johnson syndrome.
So if the patient
does experience
a rash, they
should probably
be taken off
the medication.
And remember, with
Steven Johnson
syndrome, there can
be an inflammation and
it's due to an
increase of cytokines.
And caraprazine is one
of the newer drugs.
It does have some
partial agonist action at
the D2 and D3 receptors,
but it also has the
serotonin 1A agonism.
So again, this can be
used for those patients
that have anxiety.
So a newer
drug, nuplacid,
it's pimevancerin.
This is an inversed
agonist of the serotonin
2A receptors. So an
inverse agonist binds
to the receptor and
with that it stabilizes
the receptor and it
reduces their activity.
So you see in this
picture here that a full
agonist on board
would result in this
type of line. An inverse
will bind, stabilize,
and then reduce the
action. so this would
be how this drug
would work okay what
makes this very
attractive is that it has
no dopamine no serotonin
2b no muscarinic
histaminic or alpha
action so those patients
if you're looking
for something to calm
an agitated pd or ad
patient this would be
the right drug okay
because it doesn't work
at blocking any of
the other receptors
so you're not going to
get orthostasis you're
not going to get
blocking d2 and a
parkinson's patient is
going to aggravate PD.
It's going to cause
more rigidity, tremors.
Blocking muscarinic
receptors in an AD
patient is going to
create more cognition
impairment. So this
is great because
it doesn't touch
those receptors and
it's just the opposite
of what a serotonin
2A agonist will
do. inverse binds
stabilize and then
reduces the action okay
so we have a new
drug and it's called
lumateperone it's
advertised i'm sure on the
evening news i've heard
it when the tv was
on this is um dealing
with this whole idea
of the glutamate
hypotheses of schizophrenia
so with respect to
glutamate and the NMDA
receptor if there's
dysfunction of the NMDA
receptor and this is
connected to glutamate
lower glutamate
transmission is going to
cause negative symptoms
and that's going to
be almost like again
apathy withdrawal okay
the other thing is that
if you are lowering
glutamate, as you can
see here, there is
also a lowering of
GABA, and that lowering
of GABA can promote
dopamine transmission,
and that leads to the
positive symptoms, like
delusions, hallucinations,
disorganized
thought, and then there's
a possibility that
it can promote serotonin
transmission, and
they're not sure if
that affects anything.
But it just seems like
that lowering glutamate
can actually potentiate
more negative and
ultimately positive
symptoms of schizophrenia.
So this medication,
very new, it has a
very, very strong
affinity for serotonin 2A
receptors, probably
the most all of them.
60 times greater
affinity for this
receptor versus
dopamine. Because I
mentioned the others
did have a degree
of dopamine receptor
blockade. That's
why with like
risperdone you do see
some increase in
prolactin happening.
The other thing
focuses on the fact
that this drug
is a D2 receptor
partial agonist
presynaptically.
And at the postsynaptic
receptor, it's a blocker.
So what you're doing
is you are kind of like
getting a balance
where there's going to
be some release of
dopamine, but not a lot.
And then when you get
to the postsynaptic
receptor, you're
preventing excessive
dopamine. So it's
going to keep
those dopamine
levels kind of like
balanced. And that's
a good thing because
you don't want a
total increase or
decrease of them at
all. It's modulating.
And then with this
whole idea of the
glutamate story, it's
modulating glutamate.
So that, as you can
see here, there's
some glutamate
that's preventing
the negative and the
positive symptoms.
So this is the
newer drug.
I want to just
summarize this concept.
There's one more
drug to talk about.
If there was one thing
to remember about
this lecture is
first generation, D2
receptor block,
they're going to have a
higher risk of neurological
side effects and
that has to do with
the EPS so blocking
D2 you're turning
on basically what a
person with
Parkinsonism is going to
experience slowed movements
which is bradykinesia,
rigidity, tremors
but the second
generation and how
they can have an effect
at blocking some
of those serotonin
receptors like the 2C
and the H1 block, there's
going to be an
increase in appetite.
There's going to be
an increase in weight.
an increase in lipids,
an increase in
perhaps blood sugar.
So these are things that
we also have to consider.
The newest drug
is called Benfri.
It's xanomaline and
tropsium chloride.
It's the first
antipsychotic
targeting cholinergic
receptors.
So the main action is
going to be xanomaline.
And as you can see here,
this is lipophilic.
It crosses the
blood-brain barrier.
In that, we'll
find the M1 and M4
receptors in the limbic
and in the cortex.
and what will happen
is it rebalances
again the whole dopamine
and glutamate story
and as you can see
it will decrease the
positive symptoms
decrease the negative
symptoms and it also
since it's an agonist
of muscarinic
receptors and we're
talking about now
acetylcholine there may
be some increasing in
cognitive function.
But the thing about
this type of medication
is that you would be
inducing all those
sludge effects or
dumbbells. So remember,
diarrhea,
urination,
micturation,
the whole wet
story. And that, again,
is going to now think
about bradycardia and
maybe even, you know,
bronchoconstriction.
So what do you
do about that?
In many cases,
that would limit
the use of this
medication.
Well, it's put
together with
trospium. And
trospium does not
cross the blood
-brain barrier.
It's going to stay
in the periphery. And
what it acts, it's
a non-selective
muscarinic antagonist.
So it's not doing
anything for the
agitation, but it's
preventing the adverse
effects of this drug,
which is muscarinic
overdrive, okay?
So that would
be important
because, as mentioned,
those adverse effects
would stop the
person from taking
it. So it improves the
safety of the drug
and tolerability.
And as I put in the
question mark, they're
looking at it,
you know, for the
possibility of being
a good choice now for
somebody with AD who
has psychotic symptoms,
agitation,
hallucinations, delusions.
So this is the end of
the lecture. I will
be doing a question
review, which I recommend
you listen to
because it'll review
the concepts. But if
anything, I just really
want you to understand
the difference
between typical and
atypical in their receptor
mechanisms and their
adverse effects.
Okay.
With that, I will
say thank you and
goodbye for now. And
I'll see you soon.